[Music]
breaking news this wednesday night the
prime minister ends the use of the
emergencies act the situation is no
longer an emergency why it's being
revoked and the reaction
ukraine's urgent plea to the world no
one will be able to sit out this crisis
the intensifying warnings russia is
inching towards an all-out invasion and
the anxiety among ukrainian canadians
questions about re-infections what's the
risk of catching omicron multiple times
and food fight
why frito-lay has a chip on its shoulder
with loblaw
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what the head of the
united nations calls a moment apparel
for the world the u.s secretary of state
says he believes russia will invade
ukraine before the night is over ukraine
has declared a state of emergency the
head of the military signed a
conscription order calling up reservists
between the ages of 18 and 60 and late
tonight ukraine's president addressed
the nation he says he tried to call
vladimir putin today and all he got was
silence
then in russian he appealed directly to
the russian people to stop putin before
it's too late
vladimir zelinsky said war will take
guarantees away from everyone nobody
will have security guarantees anymore he
said who will suffer most of all people
who doesn't want that to happen more
than anyone people who can stop that
people
it was an impassioned bid to save his
country the kremlin says the leaders of
two breakaway areas in ukraine have
requested protection from ukrainian
forces and there are fears a war on the
edge of europe is imminent
jackson proskow begins our coverage
tonight
russia's relentless buildup has reached
a critical stage the u.s believes 80
percent of troops are in forward
position
aircraft and ships are at the ready all
signs of an imminent full-scale attack
we believe that they are now at a state
of readiness where
they could attack at any time overnight
smoke rose from the russian embassy in
kiev as diplomats were ordered out of
the country more weapons and ammunition
from canada and european allies arrived
and ukraine declared a state of
emergency activating its military
reserves and calling up volunteers
i'm not that young anymore but i will
join them if needed said this 66 year
old librarian
ukraine's president said his next steps
would be decided by russia's next move
soon after ukrainian government websites
faced yet another cyber attack
i have a bad feeling says this resident
of luhansk i feel the burden in my soul
in the regions held by russia-backed
separatists there are preparations to
seize control of more territory men are
being conscripted to fight against
ukraine this is president putin's war of
choice
if he chooses to escalate further
russia and russia alone will bear full
responsibility for what is to come at
the u.n more condemnation of russia was
mixed with warnings that war will bring
a massive refugee crisis to europe if
the conflict in ukraine expands
the world could see a scale and severity
of need and seen for many years
yet there appear to be few options left
to deter moscow
sanctions haven't brought russia back
from the brink what happens next is up
to putin
tonight the kremlin claims that rebel
leaders in luhansk and donetsk have
requested russian military assistance to
repel what they claim is ukrainian
military aggression donna this is one of
those potential pretext foreign invasion
the type of thing the pentagon says
signals that potential russian action
could be hours not days away
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks the prospect of war in eastern
europe could unleash a humanitarian
crisis with a flood of refugees from
ukraine as neighboring countries prepare
for that hundreds of canadians have
chosen to stay in ukraine despite
repeated calls for them to leave mike
armstrong reports on their family and
friends who are anxiously watching
events unfold
how much time are you spending online
a lot
between following the news and keeping
in touch with loved ones anna pluhata
barely puts down her phone she and her
husband moved to canada nearly 20 years
ago and left behind hundreds of friends
and family members in ukraine it's
it's heart-wrenching it's
to see what's going on and feel kind of
powerless that
i cannot do anything i cannot just you
know bring them in
into safety
blue hotel says her loved ones in
ukraine seem to almost pretend nothing's
going on they're scared and worried she
says but are trying to go on with their
lives
you kind of have to
kind of hang on to some kind of
normality it is uh nerve-racking pluto's
husband is worrying about his parents
they live in eastern ukraine about 50
kilometers from the front line he's
asked them to leave
they're listening they're getting ready
they're
prepared to move if needs be but i think
they're in a state of denial that such
thing
can potentially happen this this time
around
across canada the ukrainian community is
nervous there are rallies and protests
planned in several cities more than a
million canadians have ukrainian
heritage
regardless of when your family came to
canada there's a very strong
relationship
and link to ukraine it's it's really
it's almost surreal
what that's meant is people like this
new brunswick travel agent worry about
their loved ones every waking hour that
after two years worrying about how
they're doing in the pandemic
it's not enough of colvid right now
because of craziness of president there
is
war aggression
and it's sad
now not knowing what putin's end goal
might be means there's no way to predict
what happens next the message people
send to their friends and family members
tends to be a simple but heartfelt
we are thinking of you
armstrong global news ottawa
we got a glimpse of vladimir putin's
mindset on monday and that long address
he gave to the nation his narrative
moved well beyond recognition of the
independence of two states within
ukraine and there was a telling moment
during his meeting with russia's
security council watch how putin treats
his own head of foreign intelligence
[Music]
[Music]
after that putin delivered his speech
announcing russia was recognizing
donetsk and luhansk as independent
states and said he was sending in troops
eric sorenson looks at what putin's end
game might be
russia's war of persuasion starts at
home fireworks
and russian flags in the region now
recognized as not ukraine the
pro-russian accounts on state television
and justification from president putin
himself that ukraine isn't a real
country
modern ukraine was entirely created by
russia says putin an integral part of
our history historical ties go back
centuries cultural economic religious
political putin's version allows
ukraine's national boundaries to be
erased rationalized in part by the
russian ethnicity of many people in
ukraine he doesn't
see ukraine as being a separate nation
from russia ethnically ukraine is 78
ukrainian and just 17 russian but in
donetsk and luhansk deemed independent
by moscow the russian ethnic makeup is
almost 40
and crimea already taken by russia close
to 60 percent that's one of his
arguments
that the eastern part of ukraine has
more russian speakers then what does it
mean for countries like latvia 26 of the
population has russian ethnicity more
than ukraine and estonia 25 are russian
by background but those countries have
membership in nato a protection that
ukraine does not have there is a
difference of course of being nato
member and not being like a member as
your plan shows ukraine is surrounded by
russian might and while putin's vision
may sell to many russians to most of the
world ukrainians are not russians
this is our land said president
zielinski we will not give anything to
anybody
it seems extremely costly to invade
ukraine
in a major way lisa sunstrom thinks
putin is likely to destabilize the
ukrainian government rather than
overthrow it but putin's rhetoric
suggests russia's historical destiny is
at stake putin is trying to re-establish
as much as is feasible for russia
control over areas of former soviet
territory however putin views russia's
historic entitlement a broader invasion
of ukraine would spark a terrible
conflict and it's not clear even
patriotic russians want that eric
sorensen global news toronto
now to a big development here in canada
prime minister justin trudeau says he is
ending the use of the federal
emergencies act which was invoked nine
days ago
we were very clear that the use of the
emergencies act would be limited
in time
when we invoked it it would be in place
for up to 30 days but we said that we
would lift it as soon as possible
mercedes stephenson was listening to the
prime minister mercedes what reasons did
he give to end the use of the
emergencies act
well donna in short he says there is no
more emergency downtown ottawa as you've
seen in our reporting is no longer
blockaded windsor coots other border
crossings across canada no longer
blockaded and no signs of convoys
immediately heading there and given the
incredible gravity and power involved in
the emergencies act the prime minister
said that he wanted to lift it as soon
as possible he says he's received daily
briefings that have assured him by
intelligence and police authorities that
the laws on the books and police powers
are now enough to deal with any ongoing
threats and by the way he did say he
thinks there are some ongoing threats
but that is unlikely to manifest in the
way it did in previous days just before
we went on the air we received a press
release from the conservatives they are
criticizing the prime minister saying
nothing has changed since monday when
parliament passed the emergencies act as
a confidence vote the prime minister
says he had to be sure that that threat
was gone before he moved on it now the
question is what comes next and a lot of
that will be a review of the powers and
how we got to this point the prime
minister announced today that there will
both be a joint committee of
parliamentarians that will scrutinize
the government's decision to bring in
the emergencies act and whether or not
that was necessary and a separate
inquiry into how we got to the point
that we're at now how police reacted and
foreign disinformation and funding that
may have been involved here's what the
pm said about that whether it's the uh
the committee of parliamentarians or the
inquiry
or
the court cases that are already
underway challenging the use of the
emergencies act i don't think anyone
feels that there was a low bar or that
this won't be fully scrutinized and
reflected on donna one thing that stood
out to me today the prime minister's
tone much more conciliatory to people of
all views than some of his past
statements
okay mercedes thanks ontario's premier
has also lifted the provincial state of
emergency declared february 11th some
protesters are regrouping on private
properties outside ottawa
this is private property you need to
leave i'm leaving
people in this field just west of ottawa
refused to take any questions about what
they're doing there or where they're
headed dozens of trucks and trailers
have assembled there since last
weekend's police operation in downtown
ottawa and ontario police are also
monitoring an encampment east of the
city
canada's largest public school board is
investigating several reports of
anti-semitism at a toronto middle school
one of our teachers a french teacher a
jewish teacher walked out of the room
when she came back into the room
several students surrounded her
and gave her the heil hitler salute this
particular incident was
very hateful very hurtful very upsetting
to the teacher
this isn't the first anti-semitic
incident at the school earlier this
month anti-anti-semitic graffiti was
found in the boys change room the school
says the students involved will face
consequences and it promises to ramp up
teaching about anti-semitism and the
holocaust
the protest convoy and cryptocurrency
coming up one group on a mission to
track the digital money trail
u.s president joe biden is reportedly
set to issue an executive order on
cryptocurrency and it's expected to
include efforts to regulate the sector
canadians have also tried to wrestle
with how to track digital currencies
used for nefarious or disruptive
purposes and gaviola looks at one group
of ottawa residents going after the
money trail
disruptive harassing behavior from some
members of the self-proclaimed freedom
convoy forced the shutdown of four happy
goat cafe locations in ottawa during
what should have been a much needed
opportunity to boost business the
frustration the intimidation the you
know
was just building assad and a group of
private citizens did something that's
never been done before in canada they
won a court order to freeze crypto
assets of convoy organizers
the lawsuit includes the 21 year old
ottawa resident who won an injunction
banning incessant deafening horn honking
earlier this month
[Music]
the unprecedented mirava injunction
takes aim at nine digital asset
platforms to freeze and disclose
information about funds sent to convoy
protesters shattering the myth that
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies like it
aren't trackable the common argument was
bitcoin is just for terrorists because
it's easily obfuscated and they can hide
behind the scenes but each and every
bitcoin transaction is recorded on a
blockchain a digital ledger that
provides a time-stamped record
information including accounts and
digital wallets are there for anyone
with the right tools to see
identities can be hidden behind one or
several wallets but the digital tracks
are there and authorities can catch up
to users when they exchange crypto into
canadian dollars or other fiat currency
crypto exchange bit buy is named in the
court order and says it's ready to
comply though its anti-money laundering
executive says there's something much
more pervasive and much more difficult
to track if we want to talk about evil
tools cash like i mean cash is the most
anonymous thing in the world regardless
of how it's done it's imperative to get
at the cash flow lifeblood of the
movement which has seen millions in
pledges including from extremist
political factions around the world you
cut off the money you cut off the
ability the protest to sustain itself
failing to do so means the anti-vaxx
convoy can regroup again and again
ann gaviola global news toronto
ahead the risk of getting reinfected
with omicron
canada's top doctor says the country is
through the worst of the omicron wave
more canadians have been infected with a
highly contagious variant than any other
version of the virus
don't assume that means you're immune
from being re-infected jamie morocco
explains
rachel mcintosh spent the days leading
up to christmas isolating with her
brother after catching covet for the
second time
it wasn't nearly as bad as the first few
days the first time around the 31 year
old likely first contracted the delta
variant in late april and in december
omicron
some of the numbers that we've seen
suggest that if you're infected with
sars cov2 you have about three months
where you're really resistant to
re-infection
in canada under-testing has made it
almost impossible to track our
re-infection rates but testing is widely
available in denmark between november
21st and february 11 1.8 million danes
32 percent of their population tested
positive for covid a study under peer
review from state and serum institute
noted more than 1700 were re-infections
researchers also found in rare cases
some caught omicron twice in a sample
size of over 100 000 there were 47
instances where someone tested positive
for both the original strain of omicron
ba1
and the now dominant in denmark ba2 even
when we saw reinfections it was mainly
unvaccinated young people so that'll
kind of reassure you that if you are
vaccinated
then you have quite a good protection
against this phenomenon
this bodes well for us with 84 percent
of eligible canadians fully vaccinated
the risk of reinfection at least over
the short term few months ahead is very
very small but that doesn't mean we
aren't susceptible to another mutation
rachel says she's done her part to avoid
a third boat i had three vaccines so i
even had the booster shot prepared as
best she can
should we see another wave jamie morocco
global news toronto
crispy conflict next why things are
getting chippy between frito-lay and
blah blah
a salty situation is playing out between
canadian grocery giant loblaw and the
snack maker frito-lay it has stopped
shipping its products to the loblaw
grocery chain and industry insiders say
there are more than a few snacks at
stake heather urex west explains
hey
have you tried these new chips they're
perhaps a guilty pleasure but as far as
snack foods go who doesn't love a
crunchy bag of greasy chips what's your
favorite kind of potato chip ketchup
sour cream and onion barbecue or
smoky bacon but it's those chips that
are at the center of a battle royale
between two canadian food industry
giants
in one corner food processing
heavyweight pepsico the parent company
of potato chip manufacturer frito lay in
the other loblaw the country's largest
grocer it's a massive organization not
selling to a massive organization so
this is probably a first i would say in
in the country
it means shoppers will no longer be able
to buy frito-lay's brand products at any
of the 2400 loblaw owned retail stores
across the country not at superstore no
frills or shoppers drug mart why it's
all about price i think that this
whole situation is an indication of how
challenging it's been for everyone in
the supply chain
over the last two years there's been an
enormous amount of pressure
on the cost of goods citing the rising
cost of ingredients packaging and
transportation a spokesperson for
pepsico frito lay said their prices had
to be adjusted when loblaw said no the
manufacturer stopped shipping its chips
it's not really going to affect me much
i'm not addicted to lace so if it's not
there then i will get what i want but
but i do shop different places not only
superstore except says this industry
analyst this dispute is about more than
just any one snack rising costs have
been fueling tension between retailers
and companies supplying the goods i
actually do think that pepsico is out
there representing more than just
pepsico this is about the processing
industry in canada and who at the end of
the day should pay
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with the peace tower carillon on
parliament hill
its 53 bells were played one last time
this afternoon before the tower goes
silent for renovations the carillon is
95 years old and needs some upkeep carol
owner andrea mccrady will now shift her
focus to teaching promoting carillon
studies and adapting music for the
instrument
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you